[Music]
when the Ironman film first came out I
was skeptical truth to tell I didn't
think it would succeed
I've been reading comics for years and I
was just excited as everybody else when
Marvel announced they would be launching
in their own production studio but like
anybody else who'd been looking around I
kind of cocked my head to the side and
raised an eyebrow it's kinda like what
Ironman I mean sure we're two years out
from civil war but before that the guy
had maybe four great stories to his name
yeah Captain America he got Thor you
have all these characters he can make
movies on why would you start with
Ironman and so release day came my dad
my sister and myself we went to go see
the film some two hours later we walked
out and I stood correct him I remember
looking at my dad and saying this is the
future of coming book movies everyone's
going to try to emulate this now Fox and
Sony they've been trying to do it for
years with the x-men and spider-man
respectively if they can pull this off
in future films this will create an era
of comic book movies the likes of which
we've never seen and so some 10 years
later looking back on this film the
inaugural launch of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe leading up to infinity war
which is right around the corner you
look at Thor Black Panther all these
things
the house of Marvel Studios was built on
the shoulders of Iron Men and so when
the time comes for Robert Downey jr. is
contract ends the question that
everybody's asking is should the Marvel
Cinematic Universe recast Iron Man and
that's the question we're gonna try to
answer in this video
[Music]
the story of the bottle cinematic
universe is one of near-collapse is
death and rebirth it's the story of the
Phoenix when Superman was introduced in
1938 with Action Comics number one DC
unwittingly set in motion what amounted
to a great gold rush of comic-book
superheroes and people were cranking him
out like gangbusters Fawcett
publications had been publishing pulp
magazines and suddenly he had the
president of Fawcett that went to Bill
Parker and CC back and said give me
Superman without Superman and suddenly
we had Shazam at the time a man named
Martin Goodman who'd also been
publishing pulp magazines had a company
called timely comics but unlike DC he
wasn't willing to put all his chips on
the table DC was founded in Rudin and
comic books Martin Goodman found success
in Poltz but he brought on a handful of
people Joe Simon jack kirby they created
Captain America we saw characters like
name of the Submariner the original
Human Torch Jim Hammond and they were
only a few but when world war ii ended
and superheroes began to drop off we saw
this point were timely rebranded itself
to Atlas they shifted over to our
westerns and horrors and romance stories
Atlas rebranded itself to Marvel Comics
they brought back and hired on a whole
slew of new people including Jack Kirby
and Stan Lee and the rest is history
if you were collecting comics in this
era in time the value of your comic book
was relative to whatever your local
retailer was gonna pay you you went
walking into your comic book store in
1967 with amazing fantasy number 15 the
debut of spider-man and you said how
much is this worth a handful of things
went into this calculation how many
people come walking into the comic book
store and say they want a copy of
amazing fantasy number 15 conventions
didn't exist at the time so how many
people at these look will comic book
meetups and rec center kitchens and
people's basements were looking for
amazing fantasy number 15 and if nobody
was hunting for this comic then the
retailer would give you peanuts for it
if they even bought it at all but all
this changed in 1971 a man named Robert
M Overstreet created something called
the Overstreet price guide and now there
was an annual national publication that
would tell you not just how much your
comic was worth regionally but how much
your comic was worth nationally
it would tell you if you had the first
appearance of Batman and your comic was
in pristine condition you could get a
lot for it
collectors now had a bargaining chip
they could walk into come a bookstores
and say I've got the first appearance so
the Fantastic Four I want a thousand
dollars for this person would look at
him and say you're crazy I'll give you a
hundred bucks and they would say no the
Overstreet price guide says it's worth a
thousand and then you start haggling
some lauded the Overstreet price guide
they said that it empowered the
collector market but where a lot of
those ideas were rooted in the present
people were looking to the future they
were saying this price guide is not
going to just give collectors a means to
keep from being ripped off this price
guide is going to destroy the entirety
of the comic book market is the easiest
money I've ever made ever I can't
believe it it's actually happening and
it's actually a real in the aftermath of
the 2008 mortgage crisis people were
pointing fingers that are blaming Wall
Street Wall Street was blaming the
American people they said nobody put a
gun to your head and told you to sign
your name on the dotted line of these
mortgages but social scientists and
behavioral psychologists were analyzing
the American people they said absent the
influence of Wall Street the fact that
they may or may not have been tricked
what would drive a person making thirty
thousand dollars a year to buy a house
that's four hundred fifty thousand
dollars one of the many ideologies that
were out there came from her sheffrin a
santa clara university economics
professor who effectively quoted Gregory
House when he said people want the
greatest reward for the least amount of
work with the Overstreet price guide
people began to realize something
stories of significance the origins of
important characters the first
appearance of important characters major
events like DC's crisis on Infinite
Earths in 1985 these comics tend to
increase in value over time they were
release they sold for 10 cents and now
they're worth $1,000
suddenly you had people who never had a
reason of icomics didn't even know how
to read comics who were running out and
buying them not because they cared about
Captain America or Batman because they
saw it as an investment by a comic now
for 60 cents and in 20 years
you can put your kid through college in
college Marvel and DC never really had a
reason to ask any questions for a couple
of reasons the first was because
retailers didn't tell them how many
people were buying one particular comic
they didn't tell them that a person was
coming in and they were buying five
copies of the newest issue of Fantastic
Four all they said was that this many
issues of Fantastic Four had been sold
this many issues of Batman have been
sold this many issues a spider-man had
been sold the other part of this was
that by virtue of the first fact Marvel
and DC saw comic books as a license to
print money there were changes in the
backend in 1968 Martin Goodman had
effectively sold magazine management
incorporated decadence industries but
that didn't influence the flow of comics
the stories remain the publications kept
coming and people kept buying this
lasted until the early 1990s when people
began to notice another trend because
model in DC saw increased sales of comic
books they started publishing more comic
books this trend began to build on
itself until suddenly you had stories
who were being released with as many as
12 variant covers they quite literally
flooded the market or like a man walking
down the road and finding a red diamond
it's initially worth a lot of money
until someone's hiking through a cave
and finds a wall full of red diamonds
then suddenly that man's red diamond
becomes worth a whole lot less and
that's exactly what happened people
began to realize that the kind of books
they were buying were rapidly beginning
to become worthless
and so people stopped buying them for DC
Comics this wasn't a huge issue they had
already been purchased by Warner
Brothers the model didn't have that
Marvel was out there by themselves free
floating Marvel was facing a very harsh
reality they were on the verge of
shutting down completely
I want to eat your brain spider-sense
tingling Marvel talking superheroes and
x-men each sold separately boy boobs the
lore of comic books has always been the
escape of reality whether a person's
being picked on whether it's because
they just want to be somebody else for a
day people went and they bought comic
books and they read them because they
could imagine themselves being
spider-man or Superman or Batman or
Captain America films have always been
the same way for two hours you don't
have to worry about credit card debt or
the fact that bills are coming due where
your car needs an oil change you can
walk away from the world shut down drink
a coke eat some popcorn and have the
time of your life for Marvel the
prospect of staying solvent during the
mid-90s comic bust was a difficult one
the company had effectively put itself
out on the street and said anybody who
wants to buy us feel free and there were
a couple companies that took advantage
of it and it shifted hands between 1986
to 1997 Marvel had three owners Marvel
started licensing out film rights to
various companies like a person strung
out with debt with almost no money they
sold everything they had if it was a
character that a film could be made out
of Marvel sold the licensing rights off
to that Fox got the x-men they got the
Fantastic Four Sony got the whole
spider-man universe by the late 1990s
Ike Perlmutter an audio Rod had already
found success in toy boats they were
making toys for various companies Marvel
needed a financial backer an avi arad
and Ike Perlmutter came to the rescue
they effectively bailed Marvel out they
gave it all the financial backing that
it needed
this allowed Marvel to bring in a whole
host of new riders and new artists all
under the leadership of a man named Joe
Quesada but that was the comic book side
Marvel realized that in order for them
to stay financially solvent outside of
comic books whose popularity was
beginning to wane going into the early
2000s Marvel needed another branch of
revenue that was stable come above
characters and stories had long since
left of pages of the respective
publishers and jumped on television in
the silver screen and the idea made
sense that if Marvel was going to have
superheroes in films why not make them
themselves but the backing of toy biz
wasn't enough to finance the entire
launch of a production studio that was
just too much money and so in 2005
Marvel approached Merrill Lynch with a
deal give us five hundred twenty five
million dollars will launch a production
studio you'll make your money back plus
interest but they had to put ten
properties on the line to make it happen
Captain America the Avengers Nick Fury
Black Panther ant-man cloak-and-dagger
Doctor Strange Hawkeye Power Packs
shang-chi if Marvel failed to live up to
their agreement they would have lost
them all Marvel would have been worse
off than they had been before they
approached Merrill Lynch Marvel was
backed into a corner they had to somehow
launch a production studio create a
series of movies make back 525 million
dollars just so that could be paid to
Merrill Lynch and then in turn make a
profit Marvel already brought on Jon
Favreau he was agreed to direct the
first Iron Man film but Marvel wasn't
sure who to hire for the character Jon
Favreau wanted Robert Downey jr. Marvel
said no the guy had a checkered past and
farboro said if you want me to direct
this film then you get Robert Downey jr.
if he's not in it I'm not in it
and so Marvel made it happen
if we're being honest with ourselves
this was a huge gamble it was a risk
Ironman was a character who was so
obscure to the general public Marvel's
biggest difficulty was convincing people
he wasn't an actual robot that there was
a man inside that metal suit but people
were intrigued people looked around and
they said we had the x-men from Fox we
had the Fantastic Four from Fox we have
the spider-man movie from Sony and
they've been fine but we're talking
about a company that created these
characters in turn making movies out of
them the success of Ironman catapulted
Marvel to the top Marvel was so
successful with creating their own
Cinematic Universe everybody tried to
follow suit like DC Comics with the
launch of Superman Marvel was the front
Lerner everybody else was fighting for
second place Robert Downey jr. is the
face of the Cinematic Universe when
people think of Marvel movies they think
of Iron Man people will go see a movie
they wouldn't normally see because Iron
Man is enemy spider-man is the face of
Marvel Comics he's the most popular
character Marvel Comics has and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe film for
spider-man featured Iron Man as a way to
draw people in who were a little unsure
as to whether or not they wanted to see
it Robert Downey jr. is too popular to
let go but if his contract ends and he
walks away
can anyone fill those shoes and this is
the point of this video the answer to
that question is no people will see Iron
Man they'll see Tony Stark and they will
forever associate him with Robert Downey
jr. he's the Mark Hamill of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
he'll go on to make great films he'll go
on to be featured and whatever
appearances he makes but no matter what
happens
people will see him and in the back of
their mind they'll say he's ironing
[Music]
you